starting later this month the
ride-sharing company will allow
customers in Pittsburgh to Heil
autonomous vehicles from their
smartphones for more on his bloomberg
exclusive story technology reporter max
Chapman joins us now first of all
congratulations that exclusive thank you
the great story tell us what's going on
in Pittsburgh so big news in the world
of driverless cars Buber is has been has
embarked on this crazy research project
that everybody thought would take
decades and they're trying to launch it
right now which is very exciting and in
some ways leaps them ahead of Google and
Tesla even though Google is still kind
of seen as the leader in terms of
technology so no offense to our friends
in Pennsylvania but why Pittsburgh so
Pittsburgh most people don't know this
Carnegie Mellon University is like the
place to do autonomous driving
driverless cars and basically at the end
of 2014
Travis kalanick the CEO of uber hired a
huge chunk of the Pittsburgh of the
Carnegie Mellon robotics department and
they've built up this team that it now
has hundreds of people and they're now
they're actually going beyond Pittsburgh
now they're opening offices in Palo Alto
and San Francisco as well how did I get
there so fast was it was it for to assay
or Google was saying this is years and
years away well and I think it still is
so it's important to know that the cars
and Pittsburgh will have safety drivers
and actually co-pilots I wrote in in in
one of these and it's it's kind of an
interesting experience there's someone
taking notes while you're driving around
that said it's ambitious I mean they are
on the street there are pedestrians
bikes you know everything that you could
think of one thing they've done that's
interesting and very aggressive is they
just bought a company and that's another
thing we're reporting also exclusively
Auto which is a driverless trucking
company it sounds kind of weird but it
actually may be the biggest deal that's
happened in the space yet we think it
was about six hundred eighty million
dollars and there still are incentives
so it could get bigger so how big is
this how many cars and they're going to
be in Pittsburgh by the end of this
month well by the end this month I'm not
sure I think right now it's not that
many they're saying a hundred Volvo xc90
s which is like the Volvo SUV by the end
of the year
uber also has a deal that they just
announced
now that it with Volvo to develop a
driverless car so they're going to spend
300 million dollars on that so basically
they're just pouring resources into this
project
what kind of regulation might have come
out of Pittsburgh I mean I can't imagine
that the local governments gonna be like
great good luck no problem so as far as
regulators are concerned these
driverless cars are just like regular
cars because the safety driver is
sitting there kind of with his hands or
her hands just sort of on the wheel
ready to seize control at any time
they're actually I don't believe any
specific regulations to driverless cars
in Pittsburgh but basically the DMV just
treats the safety driver as a driver and
I think obviously that's going to be
something that needs to be worked on and
regulators will need to figure out the
thing is the technology isn't there yet
I mean when I did my ride there were a
handful of times where basically the car
will kick out to the driver the car will
say I don't know what to do here driver
needs to take over usually for a couple
of seconds and you know that's why these
like train safety drivers are there
because they're just ready to do it and
in cases with there was a Tesla accident
you know a few months ago order right
and we're basically you know Tesla tells
you to keep your hands on the wheel and
it seems like maybe the driver didn't or
in any case the driver and the computer
both made mistakes are from the regulars
which is a great question what about
insurance companies do they like this
idea or not like this idea I think so I
think obviously it creates questions but
I think broadly it's going to reduce the
number of accidents so I think you'd
imagine insurers were like that on the
other hand if you game it out in a in a
very long-term way maybe there would be
so many fewer accidents that it would
drastically change the insurance
business so I think there are a lot of
questions there we don't really know the
answers yet what does this do to the
competitors like a lyft or other over
competitors out there so what's so I
think Buber has now jumped ahead of
everybody in the ride sharing space with
this lyft has a has a deal with GM
they're going that direction google says
has indicated that they want to do this
but obviously they're it's still early
days the question is how much money is
this going to cost and you know Ober is
still you know scrambling towards
profitability there involve
they've been huge investments in India
they just made a deal in China so they
don't have to keep losing money there so
I think that's the question is is how
can the driverless car thing happen
quickly enough that it'll really help
business and from your reporting doober
see this mainly as an urban phenomenon
where you're going to be replacing
taxicabs or they see it more broadly I
mean it in over the course of decades I
think they see it broadly I think they
think that the cost of taking an uber
will be cheaper than say the per mile
reimbursement that the IRS gives you so
I mean literally cheaper than owning a
car I think in the short term it's going
to be in cities and also in the US where
lot labor is a lot you know more
expensive because in China where drivers
are a lot cheaper it's not clear that
the numbers work quite as well thanks so
much that's great reporting max its max
trafficking he's Bloomberg Businessweek
technology reporter and you can read his
story in the latest edition of Bloomberg
Businessweek on news stands right now
Alex I will